bonjour Didier ça va ça va ton café
35 degrés à l'ombre Lyon est aujourd'hui
la ville la plus chaude de France et la
canicule qui s'installe mais les
organismes à rue des preuves ceux qui
souffrent le plus sont bien souvent les
ouvriers du bâtiment sur les chantiers
il est extrêmement difficile de se
prémunir de la chaleur
c'est dur quoi ça travaille un petit
effort on est
essoufflé plus rapidement nous on fait
quand même pas mal d'efforts physiques
assez intenses et chaque effort nous
plaise un peu plus quoi je suis
responsable du bonheur au travail
et ouais c'est un vrai métier oui
Laurence c'est un métier c'est un métier
racontez-moi alors vous arrivez le matin
qu'est-ce que vous faites j'arrive le
matin déjà je dis bonjour c'est la
moindre des choses la politesse c'est
quand même très important on oublie des
fois d'accord et je fais en sorte que
tous mes collaborateurs soient bien
5 ouvriers présents qui travaillent dans
une véritable fournaise thermomètre à
l'appui
44,6 ça veut dire que là les salariés
quand ils travaillent en plein soleil
ils sont à presque 52 degrés l'un des
chefs de chantier assure que ses
employés disposent de bouteilles d'eau
c'est obligatoire
le problème c'est qu'ils ne peuvent les
rafraîchir
la cabane de chantier n'est pas
raccordée à l'électricité le frigo ne
fonctionne pas donc ça va de leur poste
de travail la température qu'il fait
dans le bureau
les le café le temps oui mais ça va
aussi sur la structure de l'entreprise
commencer gérer au niveau du management
c'est quand même un peu sérieux mais il
faut se détendre responsable du bonheur
au travail non mais c'est parfait tout
va bien
la nourriture vous avez bien mangé oui
oui non c'est bien mangé végétarien
végétarien vous trouvez que les
musiciens sont suffisamment payés ouais
ouais c'est moi qui pose la question
oui
à Paris l'image est inhabituelle à la
place des traditionnelles bateau-mouches
une cinquantaine de baigneurs nage dans
la Seine
parmi eux Benoît 58 ans amateur de
natation on n'a pas l'impression d'être
à Paris c'est super naturel il y a des
algues c'est on boit la terrasse piquer
une tête dans la Seine c'était une
promesse de Jacques Chirac en 3 ans
j'irai me baigner dans la Seine devant
témoins pour montrer que la scène est
devenue un fleuve propre pas du tout la
vie des chercheurs qui conseillent
presquement au baigneur de fermer la
bouche en nageant on est en 2020 on est
en 1921 afin d'avaler le moins possible
du bouillon de culture où l'on prend ses
ébats je cite ne pas oublier non plus de
se faire vacciner contre la typhoïde la
scène étant un réceptacle
incommensurable de matière fécales trop
c'est trop en 1923 à force
d'avertissement un arrêté préfectoral
interdit fermement la baignade il y a
son temps tout pile 35 ans plus tard
Anne Hidalgo sans son maillot de bain
inaugure l'un des trois sites de
baignade autorisés pour 2025 ses
investissements importants vont
permettre de vivre dans une ville dans
laquelle on nous annonce des
températures de 50 degrés ça veut dire
une ville qui ne serait pas vivable pour
assurer la sécurité des baigneurs la
circulation fluviale et la qualité de
l'eau seront surveillés de près et
magique ce souffleur j'avais pas vu les
images il les images alors
on voit un type mais des bonnets au
possible qui est là bah oui avec sa
souffleuse sur les quais dans la flotte
on est juste sur la quai de la
magisterie je crois
mais il est aimé il a l'air bien il a
l'air cool
[Musique]
partir au Japon les mains dans les
poches Japan Airlines proposent
désormais de louer des vêtements 30
euros la semaine livrés directement dans
votre chambre d'hôtel d'après la
compagnie 10 kg de bagages en moins
c'est 60 kg de CO2 qui n'est pas rejeté
à condition de ne pas être trop exigeant
sur le style pour cet été le service
proposé ce matin c'est 5 hauts et trois
pantalons en taille L pour homme
[Musique]
sans se retourner ne pas regretter
garder les instants qu'on a voulu
attention aussi comme le rappel ce
twitos les vêtements sont taillés plus
petits au Japon il serait dommage de
devoir racheter une garde-robe et payer
un supplément pour le retour en Asie à
Singapour figurez-vous que la chaîne de
restauration rapide McDonald's vient de
lancer une formule mariage alors pour
environ 215 euros en livraison les
mariés peuvent désormais acheter
auprès de McDo un forfait pour servir
par exemple une centaine de burgers des
petits nuggets également et en tant que
McDo peut aussi vous proposer un buffet
complet bien plus opulent
je suis un petit peu triste parce que
Alex a été très prévenant très gentil on
s'entend très très bien et au-delà de ça
j'ai eu des
[Musique]
cet Espagnol a cru échanger en ligne
avec Brad Pitt pendant plusieurs mois
tout commence sur facebook l'an dernier
elle intègre un groupe de fans de la
star et c'est là qu'elle fait la
connaissance de Brad Pitt en personne de
l'autre côté de l'écran c'est toute une
équipe qui se fait passer pour l'acteur
américain soufflant le show et le froid
sur sa proie tantôt affectueux tantôt
distant grâce à des photos truquées les
arnaqueurs gagnent la confiance de leur
future victime Nathan de verre tu payes
tu casses vous avez pas cassé j'espère
dernière non bonne idée et plutôt que tu
casses tu payes encore
effectivement pardon ça peut marcher
dans l'autre sens un jour le faux Brad
Pitt dit qu'il est tombé amoureux il
promet à son interlocutrice de venir en
Espagne pour la rencontrer et lui
propose même de tourner un film ensemble
le piège se referme alors sur la victime
les escrocs lui soutiennent de l'argent
pour financer le prétendu long-métrage
l'espagnol envoie ainsi de nombreux
virements sans autre assurance que la
parole du
170000 euros au total la victime a fini
par déposer plainte pour fraude
blanchiment d'argent et usurpation
d'identité on est enfin de semaine
dernière une scène qui a lieu à Genève
donc en Suisse c'est un événement qui
organisé par les Nations unies sur
l'intelligence artificielle et on est
dans une conférence de presse un peu
particulière puisqu'elle est donnée par
des robots humanoïdes c'est à dire des
robots qui ont une apparence humaine
alors c'est une première mondiale tous
ces robots sont dotés d'intelligence
artificielle et sur les 9 robots qui
sont présents il y en a 8 qui sont
capables de parler et de bouger sans
aucune aide humaine c'est quoi les
critères qui gagnent et qui perd un
concours de sirènes alors il y a notre
engagement vis-à-vis de la communauté
des sirènes
parce que oui oui parce que je m'adresse
à la communauté des sirènes qui nous
regardent mais il y en a mais il y en a
évidemment
journaliste demande à Sofia si selon
elle et bah les robots sont capables de
diriger le monde mieux que les humains
et voici ce qu'elle lui répond
je pense que les robots humanoïdes ont
le potentiel de diriger avec un niveau
d'efficacité supérieure à celui des
dirigeants humains nous n'avons pas les
mêmes préjugés et émotions qui peuvent
parfois obscurcir la prise de décision
le H qui fait preuve d'une grande
modestie
[Musique]